مساء الخير جيدي البلد العربي الصغير تحول
الى اكبر مجمع للقواعد العسكريه الاجنبيه
في العالم على ارضه هناك بوش على الاقل
قواعد عسكريه
وفي الطريق بوش اخرى او دول اخرى بتطلب
انه يتم استضافتها على اراضي شو بوجه
الزاويه القصه يعني زاي
ولايتي الى اكبر مهم على القواعد العسكريه
الاجنبيه في العالم سؤال مثير للخيال وان
يساعدنا ان احنا نفهم الكثير من التطورات
اللي موجوده في الاقليم على الساحه
الدوليه الحقيقه الموده حصل نتيجه لاسباب
تتعلق
ضروره جيبوتي جيبوتي الصعبه وتطورات
العالم
جيبوتي الصعبه تتلخص في ان هي بلد صغير
فقير يعني عدد سكان جيبوتي احنا بنتكلم
الارقام 2017
2017 بتكلم في حدود ثمانيه وخمسين الف
نسمه نقول تسعمائه الفين و بتتكلم على
مساحه صغيره نسبيه بتكلم على ثلاثه وعشرين
الف كيلومتر مربع
ثلاثه وعشرين في المائه من سكان
الجيب ودي وفقا لتقديرات البنك الدولي تحت
خط الفقر المدقع
واكثر من
الفقر الحالي انه هي الامكانيات في
المستقبل ايه هي بلد ما عندهاش بتقول بلد
ما عندهاش من الراس معادن اليورانيوم او
النحاس او ال يعني مفيش موارد طبيعيه اخرى
عندها الزراعه او القدره على الزراعه يبقى
الزراعه ولا الصناعه ولا موارد طبيعيه
الاسباب دي على بعضها مع التجاهل العربي
لاسباب يطول شرحها
بدات
السياسيين في جيبوتي انه يفكروا في
استغلال اهم البدايه جيبوتي ايه هي اهم
المزايده الموقع والاستقرار جيبوتي واقعها
في في القرن الافريقي تحديدا هي بتتحكم في
مضيق باب المندب وعندها شواطئ طويله على
خليج عدن يعني المحيط الهندي باب المندب
طول الوقت طوال التاريخ هو مكان استراتيجي
مهم جدا واهميته بالوقت يعني الانسان تالف
تنميه اربعه وثمانين والفرنسيين بيعتبروا
مضيق باب المندب منطقه مهمه جدا اليوم في
صراعهم مع القوى الاستعماريه الاخرى
للسيطره على ثروات الدول الاخرى
عشان كده هي
الى احتلال جهوده في وقت الله في كل
الاحوال ارقام 2016 بتقول لنا انه لن يقبل
المندده عده منه اربعه من عشره مليون
برميل نفط يوميا
هو المدخل الى قناه السويس الحيويه اللي
بيمر منها حوالي ثمانيه في المائه من
تجاره العالم ما بين الشرق والغرب
وبالتالي هي مكان مهم جدا بالاضافه طبعا
الى تزايدت اهميه المحيط الهندي بصفه عامه
الى هذا الكلام عليها في وقت لاحق في
الفين وواحد
بدات جهوده وتحديدا رئيسها
اسماعيل عمر جيله يدرك انه يمكن تحويل هذه
الميزه بالاضافه طبعا الى الاستقرار لانها
بلد مستقر في محيط مضطرب في حروب فيه كان
فيه خوف في اثيوبيا اريتريا
الصومال لكن احنا بنتكلم على بلد مستقر
وما عندوش مشاكل امنيه منذ سنوات طويله
والرئيس الحالي بيحكم من سنه تسعه وتسعين
بدا يفكر مع احداشر سبتمبر انه ممكن يعرض
على الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى انها تاتي
الى جهود وعلشان تستغل موقعها الاستراتيجي
لحمايه مصالحها في مقابل طبعا دفع عوائد
على القواعد العسكريه اللي تحصل عليها
انها تقيم في جهوده وتحصل في مقابلها جبتي
على عوائل وبالفعل كانت اول دوله حصلت او
اقامه قواعد عسكريه طبعا فرنسا اللي جهود
استقل عنها سنه سبعه وسبعين الف وتسعمائه
وسبعه وسبعين لكن مع السياسه الجديده كانت
اول دوله في الولايات المتحده اللي كان
واقامت قاعده عسكريه في سنه الفين واثنين
وبالمناسبه كان اعلن عن الرقم انه دفعت
الولايات المتحده اجراء قبل ثلاثه وستين
مليون دولار وتم تحديد العقد في 2014 هو
اقامت الولايات المتحده قاعده عسكريه اخرى
بعد كده بدا الدول اخرى تاتي
ايطاليا وجاءت اليابان
وجاءت اسبانيه والمانيه القوات للاتحاد
الاوروبي ثم جاءت الهند التي وقعت عقد مع
اليابان لاستغلال قاعدتها العسكريه
الكبيره لتامين مصالحها ثم الحدث الاكبر
ان 2017 نهايه الصين لاقامه قاعده عسكريه
ليها والام ده هو الخلافه الدماء جدا الى
خطوره الوضع في جهود جهود قواعد العسكريه
لعدد كبير من القوات ال
ال ال ال المتنافسه يعني ولذلك في سياسي
اه برتغالي كتب اسمه
برونو مارس على ما اذكر هو سياسي برتغالي
كتب مقاله مهمه في مجال في في في موقع
والامريكي وكتب على العام المعيشه فرصه
الاوضاع هناك في الشوارع في جمهوريه
وفنادق هم والزاي للجنود من جنسيات مختلفه
ب يتقبله او بيتصرفوا مع بعض وتحديدا
الجنود السنيين والامريكان اللي هما
مجهولين طول الوقت بمراقبه بعضهم البعض في
كل مكتب كلمه خطيره وجهه نظره قال ان
جيبوتي هنا تبدا الحرب العالميه الثالثه
يكون الحدود فيها مش مهم لان القواعد
العسكريه للدول المتنافسه تتداول على سبيل
المثال في هذه الدوله الصغيره لكن هذه
القصه في كل الاحوال بقى عندنا مجموعه
كبيره جدا من القواعد العسكريه
جيبوتي هدفها واضح جدا واستغلال الموقع
للحصول على عائله فايه هو مصدر الدخل
الرئيسي جيبوتي جيبوتي الجيلي بتاعها
والناتج المحلي الاجمالي بلغ واحد
يعني واحد وثمانيه من عشره مليار دولار
2017 يعني اقل من اثنين مليار دولار
الاكبر اكثر من تسعين في المائه من هذا
الرقم هو ياتي نتيجه للعوائد المتحصله من
استضافه القواعد العسكريه الاجنبيه يعني
الاجارات بالاضافه الى نشاط الكافرين او
الهوه تقديم الخدمات المختلفه
والعمل لخدمه هذه القواعد العسكريه هي
التي تستضيف اعداد كبيره من القنوات يعني
ارقام الفرنسيين يقولوا لهم
1450 جندي فرنسي مولن في جيبوتي رقم كبير
جدا بالنسبه لاعداد القروض الفرنسيه مشارك
فرنسا بنتكلم على امريكا بيتكلموا على
اربعه الاف جندي امريكي في القاعده
الرئيسيه وليس القاعده الثانويه انا مصدر
معلوماتي موجوده على الاقل اللي موجوده في
التقارير العسكريين الاشاره البنتاغون
وزاره الدفاع الفرنسيه المتوفره ليست سرا
بس عايزه بحث دقيق شويه تلاقي بلدي الصين
لما قاله اقامه القاعده العسكريه ليها هي
عملتها بحيث انها تستضيف لعشره تشيني مش
بالضروره يكون فيه عشره
انا عشره الصيني في النهايه الهدف الاساسي
ان هي تحصل على اكبر عائد من اه اه اه هذا
النشاط المتولده عن هذا النشاط اما الدول
التي الجبوري فهي الدول بين
بهدف واوضح والاستفاده من هذا الموقع
الفريق اللي هو الموقع فريق انا قلت لكم
الاول انها تتحكم في مضيق باب المندب ان
الجنوب لانها بتطل على خليج عدن و على
المحيط الهندي لانها وقع في
القرن الافريقي حيث منطقه اضطرابات كثيره
زي اللي بيحصل مثلا في منطقه الصومال هو
مجموعه من السوائل الطرد بمعنى انه اه في
مجموعه من الجماعات المسلحه في جماعه
الشباب مثلا اللي تستهدف المصالح الغربيه
او زي القاعده او زي ال هو دوله الخلافه
او داعش وغيره وبالتالي دي لها نشاط اما
في منطقه القرن الافريقي
بتستهدف المصالح الغربيه او انها قريبه من
بالماده او انها قريبه من اليمن قريبه من
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وهذه الدول منها مصالح
كبيره جدا في منطقه شرق في القرن الافريقي
يعني وفي المحيط الهندي والبحر الاحمر
باعتباره انه مجرى ملاحى رئيسي
كلنا ذكرت ولكن كمان اللي هي الاساطيل
التجاريه التي هي من الشرق والغرب
وبالتالي كل هم لهم مصالح انه يترددوا في
هذه المنطقه واختاروا جيبوتي الاسباب اللي
انا قلتها اللي هي فكره اه الاستقرار اللي
ب يميزها عن غيرها من دول المنطقه
بالاضافه ل تحكمها في منطقه باب المك اذا
تحققت المصلحتين لكن الحقيقه انه ال قصدي
فيها بقدر ما فيها من مزايا هي فيها من
مخاطر لان جمودا نتوقعها في منطقه جذب وسط
توترات دليله حتى الان هي تحت السيطره لكن
لا احد يعلم بالمستقبل على سبيل المثال
لما جيبوتي وقعت من الفين وسته عقده مع اه
الامارات العربيه دوله الامارات العربيه
على اداره ميناء جيبوتي او جزء من المنهج
بوتين اسمه دوران اي على ما اذكر هذا
الميناء في 2016 وقراره فسخ التعاقد مع
شركه موانئ دبي
والاعتماد على الصينيين في ادارتها زلنا
العرض الصيني كان اننا ادير المياه
بالاضافه اننا سوف انفق يعني رقم ضخم جدا
تسعه اصفار مليارات على بنيه تحقيق احد
هذه المشروعات انه يربي الجيبوتي بمشروعات
طرق طرق وسكه حديد
تبدا يعني الجهود
اثيوبيا البلد اللي فيها مائه مليون دوله
حديثه ملهاش ما يلي يعني خاص فيها
وبالتالي هي تعتمد على الدور المجاوره
ظروف الدول المجاوره جعلتها المضطربه
جعلتها تعتمد على جبهتي بنسبه خمسه وتسعين
في المائه في استقبال
يعني
في صادراتها ووارده وبالتالي وجود خط سكه
حديد اخذوا المصالح الاثيوبيه ويعظم
المنافع
الجبوري وطبعا يقدم
الممول الرئيسي اللي هو الصين المساله
الاماراتيين واطلقت الامريكان لما اخذت
الاماراتيين بدؤوا يسعى الى اه تقليل
لاهميه لجهوده بالمهمه يقيم موانع
والقواعد العسكريه في دول مجاوره بين مره
مثلا
عليه
عمله مشاكل اخرى لانها ادخلتها في صراع مع
ال ال تركيا اه عملت مشاكل داخل الصومال
لكن قصه يتعلق ب اه ديناميكيه
شرق القرن الافريقي المعقده
اذا تم تفعيله ونجحت سياسه الامارات ان
يكون في مواد اخرى ولماذا يقلل من
الجهود ويجعلها اقل اهميه ولن يعقد طبعا
فيها تماما لكن يقلل من اهميتها شويه اقلك
الامريكان لان الامريكان
عندهم مفيد وتحفظ ان يسيطر الصينيون اللي
هو منافسهم الرئيسي على الموانئ
الجمهوريه وبالتالي يجعل مصالحهم في خطر
شعور الامريكان تضاعف من شكل القاعده
العسكريه ضخمه جدا اللي اقامها الصينيين
في جهوده انهم في البدايه الهنديه قاعده
عسكريه الهدف منها تامين فقط مصالحنا
وعمليات امداد وتمويل لكنهم شافوا قاعده
ضخمه يتسع العشره
فيها دبابات فيها مدرعات الامر اللي اثار
شعور بالخوف وبالتالي يضع شروطه في اطار
المنافسه الشديده مابين الولايات المتحده
والصين
الكلام اللي مع الجانب الاخر اللي محجب
يتكلم عنه وهو المنافسه الاكثر شراسه ما
بين اللي انت والصين
منافسه تتزايد يوم بعد يوم للسيطره على مش
جيبوتي ولا شرق افريقيا ولا موارد الشرق
الاوسط من ال ال بطول ولكن كامل المحيط
الهندي وبالتالي لما ان الصين ستقرر
واتخذت لنفسها مركزا في جهوده هي كمان
سارعت الى الحصول على موقع القدم عن طريق
منافسها عن طريق منافس اخر للصين وهي
اليابان والتي بيستخدموا نفس القاعده
العسكريه
الحقيقه انه الكلام عن جهوده
يستدعي منا ان احنا نفهم
الصوره بشكل اوسع شويه علشان نفهم اللي
بيحصل في جهوده يقدم لنا ان احنا نفهم
اللي بيحصل في كامل المحيط الهندي ودليل
يقتضي منها حلقه اخرى يحتاج منها حلقه
اخرى في قريبه ان شاء الله اشكرك
ام